This video is made possible by nor to VPN.
You really must be using a virtual private network.
And that is where Nord VPN comes in. I know,
I know it's tempting not to bother and hope for the best,
but really those stories you hear about people having their data stolen do
happen. And you don't want to make it easy for anyone to do that.
But using a VPN offers more than just security. For example,
Nord VPN lets you access any of his thousands of servers in different countries,
all around the globe. So if you've had the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements are only available in specific
geographic locations. For example,
most of European countries have strong licensing agreements restricting what
soccer matches can be viewed depending on the location of the viewer with Nord
VPN, you can change your country without even moving from your.
Sofa. Nord VPN.
Is super fast. So watching a video is a breeze, no lag whatsoever.
If you've ever used a VPNs and thought they were slow, well,
no more with Nord VPN.
And you can use all of this on all your devices very, very easily.
It doesn't matter if it's Android Chrome windows, Linux.
I don't have to six different devices on one account. Also,
there are no logs kept at all.
Unlike companies based in the EU or the U S nor the VPN is based in Panama.
So they don't have to keep logs at all, which as you can imagine,
it's great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience right now,
go to Nord VPN folder slash visual politic and use the code visual politic to
get 68% off a two year plan plus one additional month for free.
This special offer makes your subscription just $3 and 71 cents per month.
Anyway, now let's get into it.
[Inaudible].
There's you'll pull a Migos.
The Russian Federation is a country of stark contrasts. On the one hand,
the vast majority of its nearly 150 million inhabitants live and poverty,
but on the other it's one of the countries with the most international influence
mother, Russia is still a superpower.
It's an influence that of course does not come from its economic power.
After all its economy accounts for less than 2% of global GDP,
it does not have companies that are very relevant globally.
And to top it off its economic development over the past few years has been
pretty negative.
So it's not in the economy that Russia anchors his political influence,
but rather through its military.
Power, even though.
Trailing increasingly further behind the United States,
Russia is still regarded as the second greatest military power on the face of
the planet. Even today, it's only China that is threatening to bump it down.
A spot in the world's rankings.
The Russian army has approximately 900,000 active soldiers and 2 million more
and reserve. I figured that while significantly reduced over the years,
especially given that the former Soviet union once maintained more than 4
million active troops remain supported by the world's largest arsenal of weapons
and some of the most advanced Intercontinental missiles in existence because
Russia is first and foremost,
a country forged horrendous nuclear arsenal and its armed forces.
To give you an idea.
Existing calculations suggest that this country still maintains an arsenal of
nearly 6,500 nuclear weapons today.
Friends as so often happens, numbers can be misleading.
And in the case of the Russian army, that kinda seems to be the case.
[Inaudible].
As you will see,
although the figures are rendered dimensions of their armed forces are pretty
staggering. The Russians have one huge problem.
The antiquated condition of many of their weapons tanks,
submarines and other Soviet relics and open fighting.
If we had to pet the United States against Russia,
Putin's country would have a really bad time.
This is something that over the last few years has become an obsession for
Moscow,
not least because the Russian military industry is a very important one for the
entire country, for the country. And of course,
for the pockets of many of its politicians, you know,
how things work in these situations.
The fact is that the Russian military industry,
the second most important behind that of the United States is responsible for
just over 2 million jobs,
which represents no more or less than 3% of the entire labor force and
20% of all industrial jobs in the country with the exception of raw
materials.
The military industry is one of the main economic activities of the Russian
Federation, as well as an important asset and international relations.
And all of that is precisely why in this video,
we are going to tell you what the Russian army is really like.
And also what plans Moscow has put in place to try and consolidate itself as the
second military power, even above China.
So do you want to come with us to discover the strongest and at the same time
weakest part of mother Russia, if you do.
Great embarrassment before we start.
Talking about Russia's military equipment,
we need to go back a little bit to understand how this story began.
We have to go back to the years of the Soviet union. You see my friends,
the U S S R the union of Soviet socialist republics was a very poor country
throughout its entire existence, a very poor country,
but with a huge industrial base and industrial base that because of the cold war
was prepared for war at all times,
that is all Soviet factories had contingency plans to produce military weapons
and equipment if necessary. And that way throughout its existence,
the USSR was directed under what was clearly a war.
Economy.
Let's take a look at some data or the time of its downfall.
The Soviet giant had 4,000 military production and research facilities,
employing 6 million people and consuming nearly 50% of the entire central
state budget. And that's right, 50% of the entire budget,
a complete more economy and economic system geared not so much for the wellbeing
of its citizens, but for the annihilation of any potential adversary. However,
more than half of this huge military industrial power was lost as it had to
close during the great crisis arose after the disintegration of the USSR crisis,
in which Russia lost around 20% of its GDP between 1991 and
1993.
[Inaudible].
The crisis was so great and had so many repercussions for the Russian
Federation.
Didn't manage to match the GDP at hand during the Soviet era until 2004.
And alongside all this its military industry suffered.
What is basically an apocalypse,
nearly 70% of military companies disappeared and the sector lost more than three
and a half million jobs, 60% of his workforce.
And that is not all in addition,
much of the production facilities stayed beyond Russia's new borders and
countries that became completely independent after the dissolving of the Soviet
union countries, such as U Korean,
which compromised a total of 15% of all Soviet industrial production.
Indeed this detail has been key a top priority and Russia's foreign policy.
Let me explain the military industrial complex was scattered across the Soviet
geography.
The economic interdependence and disrespect was enormous so that when the USSR
fell apart, Russia faced a two-fold problem. Firstly, as I have mentioned,
the crisis significantly, we can industrial capacity. And secondly,
it's remaining military production companies and its army relied heavily on
supplies, technology,
and equipment that were known in the hands of other countries.
And this is largely what explains Russia's difficulty and maintaining fierce
control over some of the former Soviet republics, such as Ukraine, but.
Yes, carry on.
Constant investment to keep them up to date. However,
after the fall of the USSR, Russia simply had no money left.
This is why Russian military spending in 1998 was one third of what it had been
in 1992 military spending fell from almost
48.7 billion to just over 16.2 billion.
And as I'm sure you can imagine this budget reduction was accompanied by a total
collapse and military production take note of this and the late 1990s Russian
military production that counted for 10% of what be produced in 1991,
only 10% as disastrous. However, hold on just one moment,
because everything began to change with the arrival of the new millennium with
the 21st century,
it came one of the great protagonists of international politics over the last
two decades. I am of course, referring to who else, but Vladimir Putin,
the president that some already called the new SAR of mother Russia.
Yep.
The thing is when Putin came to power,
he found himself in a catastrophic situation in terms of the Russian armed
forces. Only 20% of military equipment was relatively recent.
I eat only 20% of the gear was functional. And not only that,
but the Army's to react and deploy forces was lower than ever.
These are problems that in many cases still persist today. Take for example,
what happens to aircraft carriers? Well, at the beginning of the 21st century,
the United States maintained the fleet of 14 of these ships dotted around the
globe. Russia barely had one.
And that one was far from top of the lane.
[inaudible] is an aircraft carrier from the final stages of the USSR with
technology from the early 1980s.
But which due to various deficiencies was not fully operational until 1998,
but this is not the only example we can find of the Russian military habitually
presenting better numbers.
And the reality another case can be found and his tank and venturing,
you see on paper, Russia has the largest fleet of tanks in the world.
According to estimates,
they have between 15,000 and 20,000 units and even higher amount than
all of the natal countries combined. So what's the problem. The problem is,
is that most of them are old,
very old Russia continues to operate former Soviet tanks dating back for the
1960s and seventies.
As you can imagine,
this creates a lot of weaknesses that among other things has serious
implications during the war or rather the attack on Georgia in 2008,
You see the Georgian war was Russia's first open war after the fall of the
Soviet union.
And it serves to test the effectiveness of his arguments and the capabilities of
his army. And the truth is they failed the test, all sorts of problems,
cropped up lack of coordination between military commands, lack of precision,
Reverend rate,
poor maintenance of military equipment and poor personnel instruction problems
that slowed grew breasts,
despite Russia's enormous superiority and the Russian army recorded many more
problems and many more losses.
And it had estimated all of this was a huge headache for Moscow that was
suddenly faced with a harsh reality.
Its armed forces did not correspond to those of a large superpower.
[Inaudible].
About this for one moment. If the invasion of a small country like Georgia,
that didn't even bother to resist was wrought with a constant succession of
mistakes and problems of all kinds,
what would happen and the event of a much larger operation.
Can you imagine what would have happened if the confrontation had been with
natal troops?
Well.
That was exactly the question that was asked and Moscow.
And the response came shortly thereafter in 2011,
when Vladimir Putin presented a comprehensive program to modernize the Russian
armed forces, a goal that went on to become the highest national priority.
We are talking about the so-called SAP program,
a program that invested a gigantic investment of up to $650 billion to
buy and develop new aircraft,
new tanks and especially submarines rockets and missiles.
Lots of missiles, all of this with the aim that by 2020,
at least 70% of its military systems could be considered advanced and fully
operational. But as naysayers will insist that this is in fact 2020,
what results has this plan achieved?
Has the Russian army improved substantially over the last 25 years? Well.
Stumbling block.
If there has been one event that has disrupted the plan of modernization of the
Russian army as clearly being the Ukrainian war and the annexation of Crimea,
as we have covered in previous videos,
this military action resulted in harsh sanctions for Russia from the United
States and many other Western countries sanctions that brought the Russian
military industry and to focus what's more the fact that Ukrainian government
emerging from the Euromaidan and opposition to Russian control,
managed to endure has caused Moscow to lose direct access to some of its major
military supply.
Yes.
For example, aircraft manufacturer,
Antonov now Ukrainian state owned company had agreements with the Russian
defense ministry to provide them with a new eight and 70 an eight and one,
two for military transport aircraft. Not only that,
but significant engine supply contracts were also underway for new Russian
aircraft and helicopters from the Russian manufacturers, mill and camo,
as well as some from Yan CoLab. In addition to all this,
because I'm very important contracts for the supply of components and technology
for the Russian frigate to modernization program also fell through and seriously
disrupted Moscow's plants.
The greatest example is in the manufacturer of the new Admiral Gira Trav class
frigates whose gas turbines were manufacturers by the Ukrainian company,
Zuora mush.
Okay.
As you can imagine,
all these contracts were suspended by the Ukrainian government,
after the invasion,
forcing Russia to seek alternative local or Russia friendly suppliers.
This is no easy feat,
both for the level of development or by coupling and technological
compatibility.
And that's not all following the events in Ukraine and the subsequent
international sanctions,
the United States and many ally countries halted the sale of Julius electronic
components, both civilian and military,
such as special glass and steel that were used to manufacture Russian weapons
and satellites. And for which Moscow spent about $500 million each year.
But given all the obstacles less focused on the results achieved and the weapons
systems Russia currently hunts the situation is such that despite the enormous
efforts made the problems still persist and an estimated 50% of grinned forces
can be considered to be modern. Take, for example,
the case of the Russian T 14 Armata tanks, the crown jewel,
and one of the steps considered key to modernizing their ground forces.
Initially Russia was planning to equip itself with 2,300 tanks of this tape by
2025. However, the budget has been so diluted that in the end,
these 2,300 tanks have in fact only resulted in 132.
Do you thought the situation has seemed to grim in the post-Soviet crises we
described earlier, Russia is currently in the middle of a double crisis,
an economic and monetary crisis. For example,
the ruble has devalued 60% against the dollar over the last decade.
And then there is a second diplomatic crisis.
One that we have told you has greatly restricted Russia's access to key markets
necessary for modernizing its military sector.
However, in spite of everything,
and even though the objectives may have not been fully met,
the truth is that the period of 2011 to 2020 has been the stage of the greatest
military modernization since the fall of the Soviet union.
Of course of the last decade,
we have seen how the Russian air force has incorporated nearly 100.
Sukhoi asked to use 35,
their most advanced fighter with specifications close to the most recent
American and European fighters. In addition,
the old Soviet Tupolev one sex or nuclear capable bombers are being upgraded to
create the T U one sex or an variant from which Russia seeks to incorporate 10
units. Then on the Marine side, which is where the Russians are weakest.
The program has given absolute priority to boring class nuclear capable,
submarines submarines with 16 missile launchers capable of carrying six nuclear
warheads. Each my friends,
the cost of building equipping and assembling just one of these submarines,
it's close to $1 billion. They are the new crown jewel of the Russian arsenal.
And at the time of making this video,
there were already four vessels of this tape, sealing the seas.
And so we could continue with many more types of equipment.
[Inaudible].
The SAP program has not been completed,
but despite this elite and modern equipment for the Russian armed forces is
undeniable.
But having said that there was one key issue that could influence the future of
all these plants.
And what I mean is the military capability of an army has a lot to do with its
industrial capacity. And today for countries like Russia,
its international influence is linked to his ability to manufacture and sell
modern military equipment.
This becomes even more critical if the country is going through a structural
economic crisis.
So the burning question is where is the real problem with a Russian military
industry? Well, to be specific,
the biggest weakness lies and its enormous inefficiency.
Russia.
Industry is first and foremost, a state driven and state run industry.
And that is causing a lot of problems such as slow technological development,
which can leave it behind not only the United States, but also China.
So let's look at an example that illustrates what we're talking about.
Take the case of the Russian military company,
rustic Ross tech as a company that builds just over $25 billion and has
529,000 employees.
It's North American rival the U S Lockheed Martin has 105,000 employees,
five times fewer yet at generates more than $53.7 billion in
revenue or nearly twice as much.
Rustic.
I'm wondering, but grant, is that really bad?
Potent?
Well, let's say it is a sane. Russian are huge corporations,
very bureaucratic and complicated that have the dual mission of not only
developing military equipment,
but also like every public enterprise of employing as many people as possible
throughout the land.
Also adding to its sluggishness is the fact that resources are scarce because
just imagine how much gets chewed up by a payroll of that size.
Obviously the ability to retain the best talent is quite low.
This intern generates a very significant technological gap and remember the arms
market is not very different from any other competitiveness and innovation are
key. Well,
the fact is that these problems and the shortfalls of the 2011 to 2020 plan is
what has led Putin to announce a new plan with almost an identical budget.
The 2018, 2027 state armament plan. However,
unlike in 2011, the state's resources are much more limited.
To date.
As you can see during the era of leather mule Putin,
the Russian armed forces have experienced a huge make-over nevertheless,
they still have three major problems facing them today. Firstly,
the equipment is still largely outdated and ill-equipped beyond the big programs
that the Russian government showcases in a grand way and reality,
the advances overall are not so great. Secondly,
Russia's military industry remains inefficient very bureaucratic and
complicated.
They are no longer just challenging and competing with us military companies,
but also with new players in the game like China and thirdly,
the country's structural economic crisis raises serious doubts about his ability
to continue financing the updating and operation of its armed forces. And yet,
despite all of this,
the efforts of Latin mere Putin's government so far have caused Russia to
maintain its status as a superpower.
Something that in the late nineties was in serious dent,
but now it's over to you.
Do you think Russia is as strong and fearsome as Moscow propaganda would have us
believe and how long after I finished recording this? Well, I wind up dead.
Leave your answer in the comments. We really hope you've enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Every couple of days you can click the little alarm down there and we'll give
you an update whenever we release one.
Also don't forget to check out our friends on the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode, but we're not my dulcet tunes.
Also this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you on the next video.